نعم ، صباح الخير كريستي وفيل ، هذا
أمر تنفيذي
وقع عليه الرئيس بايدن أمس وما يفعله هو إلغاء
تجميد سبعة مليارات دولار من
البنك المركزي الأفغاني الذي تم
تجميده خلال الصيف عندما استولى طالبان
على
البلاد وقسمها إلى دلاء.  سيذهب ثلاثة
مليارات ونصف المليار دولار من هذه
الأموال إلى صندوق استئماني
سيتم توزيعه في نهاية المطاف
كمساعدات إنسانية في أفغانستان
وبالطبع هناك حاجة ماسة للتمويل حيث تعاني
البلاد من
المجاعة والفقر
الجماعي ثم النصف الآخر من الثلاثة
و  سيتم تخصيص نصف مليار
لتمويل التقاضي المحتمل
لعائلات 9 11 ضحية الذين كانوا يسعون للحصول على
هذا التعويض لسنوات وقاموا
بمقاضاة طالبان لدورهم في
إيواء العقل المدبر للهجمات أسامة
بن لادن الآن لن يتم الإفراج عن أي من هذه الأموال بشكل
صحيح  بعيدًا في حالة
المساعدة الإنسانية ، سيحتاج القاضي
أولاً إلى منح الإذن لإنشاء الصندوق الاستئماني الجديد
إد ومن هناك
سيتم توزيعها على الأفغان
والمسؤولين الأمريكيين يقولون إنهم يتخذون خطوات
لضمان عدم عودة الأموال في نهاية المطاف
في أيدي طالبان ، لكن ليس من
الواضح بعد كيف يخططون
لتحقيق ذلك